shout out to them yeah were there a lot
of women used to beat that I used to
[__] these [__] up well for what
though for disrespect to me various
reasons various reasons various reasons
but you know what anybody you regret
[__] up like damn I I really was
tripping that day I really that didn't
deserve a ass beating you know I feel
like everybody deserved what they had
coming
okay so it's safe to say you're nice
with your hands yeah yeah uh-huh you
ever have you ever took the L on the
other side of I got beat up I got beat
up a lot of times on a one-on-one or a
jump I got beat up on one-on ones many
times and it's always I'm always
fighting the big [__] I'm never
fighting no little [__] the BBWs yeah
no I'm just talking about big [__]
like like WNBA like big than me you see
how I'm big Rebecca Lobo who's that uh
she's played for the Liberty back in the
day but yeah even the [__] I beat up
even the [__] that broke my heart they
be proud of me now
today uh you how many times have you had
your heart
broken three times three yeah how old
are you
22 that's not terrible that's not too
bad um what was the mo like for you like
was it
cheating this dude left me for a white
girl oh that's rough when I was in job
corpse damn Hey listen I'm white and I
don't even [__] with white women so I my
wife's Mexican my baby mom is
Mexican I I I've never ever ptok in the
in the white women so yeah he's tripping
the one thing you know listen the one
thing about white women though is like
all my friends like I have a lot of
black friends to date white chicks and
like for the most part um they are very
like uh they're they're the most
gullible idiotic women of all time like
I wish I wish I had it in me to date
someone who reminded me of my sister or
my aunt or something I like white
[__] they fun yeah they're fun and
gullible and kind of you know God bless
them you know they uh they definitely
sign the tax money right over you know
what I'm
saying they sure do um so so that was
was that the last guy broke your heart
the last dude that broke my
heart was a dude from Jersey but I'm
over that [__] now for real for real in
real
life I don't even talk to these [__]
no more wow I can't even walk with them
no more do you feel like um because
you're a new bubbling artist you have so
much stuff going on that like is
probably do you think it's like a good
or a bad thing to have a relationship
right now just have fun girls have fun
and focus on on focus on your hustle
just have fun later you got to focus on
taking over the rap game exactly
100% don't do it don't do
what don't do what yo you funny yo um
talk about your your friendship with
Buster rymes Buster rymes obviously is
uh one of the greatest of all
time yo shout out to Buster he he bought
me my first diamond chain that's sick
yeah he B he he bought me two Diamond
chains nobody know that I lost the first
chain yeah when Buster RS bought me that
diamond chain he replaced it yeah he
replaced it so you told him like spent
the bag yo I got a crazy story to tell
you what happened so RS buys me a
diamond chain right okay I lose it
performing with him in 50 Cent on stage
okay at least at least you didn't lose
it in I didn't lose it from no reason I
was on the stage I was Buck Wilding Flex
by the way SI Flex yeah S Flex yeah I
was like Buster I lost the chain he was
like what how how you L your said I was
on stage it just fell off yeah he was
like that's not my fault because like if
I'm on stage performing that's the
jeweler's for or whatever but we [__]
with the we [__] with the Jeweler so so
what happened was he B me another chain
and nobody knew and I just acted like I
never lost the chain same chain same
chain same chain right spent that bag
wow but then it's going to [__] your
head up the dude came like listen so
mind you I lost the chain and he bought
me a new chain right then Buster RS was
performing at a show and some guy just
came to him and was like listen I found
the chain like I know this means a lot
to scar and you and I know how important
this chain is so I want to give it to
you so now you got two so now I got two
chains yeah wow shout out to Two Chains
check you out shout out to Buster rymes
crazy crazy story yeah were you are you
nervous performing like on stage with
Buster Rhymes and 50 Cent yeah man I'd
be [__] my pants it was too much
people bro and I was just looking at
everybody I'm just like man I got to
kill it I can't [__] they show up yeah
cuz bust is like one of the greatest
performers of all time if not the he's
like top three for sure yeah he might be
number one I love Buster arms the way
him and uh and spliff be on stage and
they do the thing where like he turns
them down and he starts rapping all
quiet and then he turns up yo spliff mad
funny bro no it's crazy best hype man of
all time yeah no it's crazy everybody
who never if you like ever want to watch
a live hip-hop show and like take some
notes go watch Buster Rhymes perform